[Music]
let's flash back to season two aha good
lord I want to walk through some of your
favorite least favorite moments of that
season I had therapy for that Oh God
what was your favorite look from season
two my favorite look from season two was
my circus director my two of hearts the
gold I really liked that look I thought
it was very you know kind of fantastic
inside least favorite least favorite
we'll go ahead and say the wedding dress
I thought it was a great concept I
thought it was a great idea she's not a
seamstress and there was a lot of fabric
did you work on your sewing skills
between 1/2 because that's always Roos
big complaint as these girls won't know
how to sew anymore I know but not they
never really made great costumes anyway
do they sashay away
favorite lip sync from season 2 well I
would have to say the best lip sync on
season 2 was you know 2 of hearts with
Tony we killed that
[Music]
I was when she started doing all the
back flips and flip-flops I was like oh
man you have to get put your best foot
forward
literally and like when Sahara and I did
our lip synch which so also was a really
great lip synch she was on point and
then sailed off the stage I knew at that
minute I was gone I was like oh I I
can't really death drop I don't have
insurance
favorite challenge from season two has
to have been the stripper challenge
there was a pole and we had dainty
outfits on and it was just great and
biggest regret from season two biggest
regret from RuPaul's Drag Race Season
two was picking on mystique about her
weight but she did win the eating
contest and of course we just went for
the jugular
and ever granted every day because when
I saw her crying on the TV it broke me
it really upset me and I've she's one of
my closest friends now but at the time I
couldn't even imagine all these people
making fun of you but is something you
can't control what are you bringing to
the table this time what kind of Morgan
are we gonna see they'll unapologetic
about a lot of things that I do or say
but when I'm wrong I admit that I'm
wrong I like the truth I want it to be
straight up but the girls and that's
what they're gonna get from me there's
no kind of gray area with me it's black
or white yeah they love me or you hate
me there's no middle ground with Morgan
go fix your hair
Chicago
you